quand on les voit sur les rivières
souvent on ne remarque même pas les
barrages
juste au québec il y avait pourtant des
milliers ces obstacles aménagé par les
humains sont la cause principale du
déclin de l'anguille d'amérique
dans le reportage qui suit des
autochtones et des chercheurs s'unissent
pour que ce poisson retrouve son
territoire d'antan
[Musique]
voltage tour au sein c'est bon c'est bon
tout juste en face de québec au beau
milieu de la ville de lévis se déroule
une pêche pas comme les autres ce matin
on a fait une pêche électrique à
l'embouchure de la rivière etchemin donc
à peu près sur 100 mètres de distance
dans l'eau ça nous permet d'en fait
assomer si je peux dire le poisson pour
dans le but de pouvoir les
les capturer avec un filet cette pêche
électrique s'inscrit dans un projet
spécifique à l'anguille d'amérique
le conseil de bassin de la rivière
etchemin veut ainsi acquérir des
connaissances supplémentaires sur
l'espèce afin de redonner à l'anguille
accès à son territoire naturel désormais
inaccessible c'est difficile pour langue
et parce qu'elle a perdu beaucoup de son
habitat originel par le biais des
barrages qu'on a mis des obstacles
qu'elles rencontrent maintenant
l'anguille d'amérique ne se porte pas
bien considérés autrefois comme l'une
des espèces de poissons les plus
répandues sur notre territoire
sa population subit un déclin sans
précédent depuis des années la pollution
les turbines des barrages et surtout la
perte d'habitat en sont les principales
causes
depuis 2012 l'espèce a été désignées
menacées par le comité sur la situation
des espèces en péril au canada le caw
sépaq
dans ce contexte l'équipe du conseil de
bassin de la rivière etchemin
c'est que la pêche ne sera pas facile
aujourd'hui mais elle garde espoir
la joie aura été toutefois de courte
durée ouais elle nous a fait sursauter
parce qu'on pensait que c'était de
l'anguille 1 qui malheureusement s'est
rendu compte que c'était une lampe roi
alors un peu déçu mais on continue
l'anguille d'amérique un parcours
singulier
c'est au large de la floride dans la mer
des sargasses qu'elle se reproduit une
seule fois dans sa vie avant de mourir
ces rejetons entreprennent ensuite une
longue migration en direction du
groenland
certains s'arrêtent au canada où ils
passeront l'essentiel de leur vie
parfois plus de 20 ans
on trouve des anguilles partout dans
l'est du pays dans les eaux douces des
lacs et des rivières mais aussi dans les
estuaires et les eaux marines qui
s'ouvre sur l'océan atlantique
de retour sur la rivière et de chemin
c'est à une vingtaine de kilomètres de
l'embouchure que les anguilles rencontre
leur premier obstacle quasi
infranchissable mais peut être plus pour
longtemps pour assurer la survie de
l'espèce
le conseil de la nation huronne wendat a
décidé de prendre les choses en main sur
les cours d'eau de son territoire
traditionnel il aménage des
installations favorisant la remontée des
anguilles ce qu'on voit c'est la rampe
qui va s'ancrer dans le roc sur lequel
vont venir s'installer une rampe de
montaison qui constitue un substrat est
spécifique à langue et donc c'est un
substrat moulé en polymère
ce substrat loi permet à langue et avec
un fil de l'eau l'on a fait
permet à l'envié de remonter d'effectuer
sa montaison autrefois empêcher des
anguilles très haut en amont de la
rivière etchemin
mais lors de leurs recherches les
scientifiques ont eu peine à en trouver
quelques unes en fait jusqu'à l'an passé
on avait pas capturer danger dans le
dans le lit même de la région on croyait
fortement qu'elle se rendait jusqu'ici
on n'avait pas de preuves l'an passé du
rang des observations nocturnes sur la
chute est chemine en aval du barrage
on a détecté trois ans gains en
montaison final donc au sommet des
chutes dont qui avaient terminé leur
leur montaison puis entre la chute puis
le barrage ici il n'y a plus d'obstacles
donc le fait de découvrir deux langues
et qui réussit à monter naturellement
les chutes
on s'est dit ok bon on installe acquis
en gros louis picard a participé à la
recherche des anguilles plusieurs
sorties ont été sans succès on
commençait à désespérer un petit peu
mais sur une chute un peu plus en aval
on a trouvé
heureusement notre dernière sortie et
comme constaté c'est que au moins il ya
un an ne puisse attendre tranquillement
que je veux faire une passe
un aménagement pour les pas franchis
puis d'ordonner une nouvelle habitude
qui ont perdu auparavant vélo c'est
fascinant
grâce à cette échelle 49 hectares
d'habitat sont ainsi redonner à
l'anguille languit fait partie de notre
histoire
elle a permis aux premiers colons de
survivre durant les longs mois d'hiver
au milieu du 20e siècle on comptait
jusqu'à 600 pêcheurs commerciaux
d'anguilles au québec
cette espèce est aussi très importante
pour les autochtones du canada qui la
pêche depuis des temps immémoriaux d'une
ressource qui étaient utilisés par les
romains date et leurs ancêtres donc les
hurons s'en servait comme de provisions
mais qui avait aussi d'autres vertus
médicinales
pourquoi aujourd'hui on s'intéresse à la
langue et parce que la nation huronne
wendat aux hackers l'intégrité
écologique de son territoire que les
espèces comme langue et qui oui ont une
relation historique avec la nation mais
aussi sont en déclin
donc on a un besoin si on veut de
conservation c'est ce qui a amené la
nation à s'intéresser à l'anguille
[Musique]
juste au québec près de 3200 barrages
sont situés dans l'air de répartition
historique de l'espèce 94% d'entre eux
sont difficilement franchissable ou
infranchissable par les anguilles lors
de leur déplacement vers l'amont des
cours d'eau
depuis 2014 le conseil de la nation
huronne wendat a fait un immense travail
de recherches pour connaître la
répartition contemporaine et historique
de l'anguille dans trente deux bassins
versants sur son territoire traditionnel
il a aussi répertorié l'ensemble des
ouvrages bâtis comme les barrages et les
ponceaux et vérifier si les anglais
pouvaient les franches et
en 2019
ce sont trois mille huit cents hectares
d'habitat qui ont été redonnés aux
anguilles grâce à 10 aménagements sur
des cours d'eau
et ça continue on dit d'ailleurs que la
réparation historique de langues elle
c'est tout les amateurs d'eau douce
auquel l axe ça veut dire qu'ici au
québec si aucun barrage blanquer ce but
je ça déchire sinon on va se rendre en
tête de bassin versant
tanguay vont remonter jusqu'au bout et
pour montrer que c'est vraiment les
obstacles qu'on lui mette sur le sur son
chemin qui vont la red epic yvon qui
vont restreindre son habitat les hurons
wendat ne sont pas les seuls à
s'intéresser au sort de l'anguille
d'amérique
le ministère des forêts de la faune et
des parcs du québec mène aussi des
recherches sur l'anguille want et
prochain assure aujourd'hui hawaï à rien
non il veut déterminer les meilleures
techniques pour détecter si l'espèce est
présente ou non dans un cours d'eau à sa
malle arrière est jamais on est en train
de valider différents engins de pêche
pour en faire un potager le standard et
ces pauvres à ces genres angèle de pêche
ont bien fonctionné pour s'assurer de
cas qu'on va vouloir valider la présence
ou l'absence d'un gain dans un cours
d'eau d'utiliser les bonnes méthodes
enfants des méthodes qui sont reconnus
efficace ça parce que ça
le ministère test des cages les pièges
mais aussi s'assurer de l'efficacité de
la pêche électrique de l'observation
nocturne et de l'adn environnementale
[Musique]
avec un protocole standardisé
il sera plus facile d'assurer la
protection de l'espèce
on va demander en fait quand qui vont
les promoteurs vont refaire un barrage
mais on va s'assurer qu'elles des
méthodes de mitigation et ça serait que
les travaux qu'on fait dans nos rivières
soit respectueuse cevital de l'ail et
les prochaines années nous diront si
tous ces efforts ont porté fruit
on y confiant que longuet se rend jusque
ici on est confiant que la nuit est
d'attirer par l'aménagement qui est en
mesure dans le monde dont grands du lot
c'est seulement deux secondes puis de
trouver une fierté en fait d'aider cette
espèce le qui va pas bien puisque une
fierté défaire de redonner à l habitat
qu'elle a perdu autres à pois florian
perret et son équipe prendront le relais
de la nation huronne wendat pour
l'entretien de l'échelle sur la rivière
et de chemin moi je suis très optimiste
par rapport à landing parce qu'en fait
on a vu d'en haut niveau scientifique
justement de créer des dépassant guigne
des échelles anguilles
ça permet vraiment à l'andi de regagner
des territoires en amont il ya quand
même beaucoup d'attentes milieu 20 qui
se mobilisent en même temps pour cette
espèce le fait que oui oui je suis
confiant
[Rires]
[Musique]